OK我们看从卡32开始看
卡32 2.6的ATR
它已经在21MA和50均线盘整了很久
然后也进行了一个摘幅的震荡
那第一次回踩冲上了50均线
卡32应该会买
它跌不下去了应该
对所以说
它应该会再冲前高
也是偏看偏买
应该能到两倍的R
卡33
卡33 2.9的ATR
我们看一下
它在进行长期的一次
这个波段向上之后
进行了第一次的回踩
21MA均线
然后有一个undercut rally的动作
也倾向可买
卡34
卡34的话
4.5的ATR
就是能不能回到前高的问题呗
我觉得有点难
卡34的
倾向于震荡再看
卡35
卡35的话
39天前的高点
多头排列了吗
还没有
所以说
有
在这个点的话
它虽然很接近
前高
但是很有可能冲上去
再砸下来
卡35
我也不会在这个地方买
我会等它多头排列之后再买
卡36
卡36是个好图
卡36的话
因为它
多头排列
然后在21均线上进行盘整了
你看到没
那还没有冲击新的高点之前
它在高位盘整
这是我想看的图
卡36绝对会买
卡37绝对不买
高位跌下来
跌得太快了
21均线这边
也没收稳
所以在这个地方
它得再盘整盘整
卡37我不会买
卡38的话
第一次冲高回落
感觉是跌到了前高
的位置
也不买
因为它才刚刚回来
这种pullback我还不会买
我等它在21
也没均线之内进行一个盘整
然后我才会买
卡39
卡39的话
它稍微更弱势一些
它跌破了21均线
然后回踩了50均线
所以它需要一点盘整
卡39
不买
卡40
50均线和21均线
是不是个多头排列的情况
不买
卡41
卡41的话
高位
冲高之后
4天之后
回落到21均线
如果它能够在这里进行盘整的话
我倾向它是可以再继续冲的
但现在还没有拐头
卡41我也不买
好多不买
卡42
6.6的ATR
风险更大一些
它在21均线上一直踩着
那这次能不能站上呢
还没有出现迹象
没有在21均线上出现一个稳定的状况
看
偏看偏不买
卡43
这个就是和42完全不同的情况
回踩了21均线
然后的话
有拐头出去要重新冲的一个征兆
嗯
卡43偏
看偏买
但如果它能够离这个21MA均线更近的话
我肯定会买
卡44
5.1的ATR
嗯
之前的20天震荡有点大呀
不是那个能够稳定的缩好
然后也不是多头排列
卡44我也倾向不买
卡45
5A卡45是一个很低的ATR的值
两个月前产生了新高
嗯
卡45也比较看一看
不是特别清楚它能够在
我觉得它跌不下去
就意味着它不会超过1.5的ATR
对
但是它能够继续充吗
嗯
这点有点难确定
卡45看
卡46
4.4的ATR
嗯
21金线上没有支撑
不买
卡47
卡47 5.2的ATR
嗯
它在迅速回踩了50
然后现在又重新站上了21EMA
但是它不是特别收敛
收敛的情况下
我可以考虑给它冲上去
嗯
卡47也不是特别想买
卡48
27天前是高点
然后这里有一个
51和
50和21EMA均线的
一个多头排列
它迅速站上去了
说明能量很强
嗯
卡48可以考虑买
卡49
嗯
不想买
因为它在21EMA均线上
没有得到一个有效的支撑
卡50
卡50的话
1.7的ATR
不是特别想买
尽管它的这个盘整
做的挺好的
在均线上
嗯
好
就到此为止
!
谢谢观看